j'ai choisi le côté quand mon but est de
vivre dans un monde imaginé ça imaginez
mais vous savez notre imaginaire a été
tronquée puisque on nous a donné des
éléments d'une culture qui n'est pas la
nôtre
il fallait bien remettre les pendules à
l'heure redonner au peuple des éléments
de sa culture et de sa vie de tous les
jours de son environnement
mon expérience à sion vient beaucoup de
mes souvenirs d'enfance
tout d'abord d'une situation un oiseau
qui passe une feuille qui tombe un nid
de fourmis une situation et émaux
l'imagination fait le reste
mais surtout je m'inspire beaucoup de
notre histoire de l'histoire de notre
peuple de nos peuples
car notre histoire n'a pas commencé en
comme souvent le coin elle a commencé il
y à des siècles ailleurs un lourd
n'oublions surtout pas que un conteur
métier la mémoire du peuple